hi my name is marcus sanderson i'm a
chef of red rooster harlem and i'm gonna
make fried chicken
fried chicken for me it's such an iconic
recipe that speaks sort of to american
culture very often southern american
culture i want to listen to some really
good music sit outside eat it with my
hands and just share it with some
friends you know that's living that's
good life
so i'm from ethiopia and the main spice
plant in ethiopia is called berbere so
for my chicken shake the main ingredient
is per breath it's a beautiful sort of
mild chili blend this is to make sure
that the chicken gets this smoky
beautiful spicy flavor that makes our
fried chicken so very special
this dish i was really intimidated by
right you know i'm 50 yards away from
sylvia the most famous african-american
restaurant in the country and they have
really good fried chicken so for me i
really thought about how to do different
and not serving the white meat serving
dark meat bone in helped me really sort
of take a stand on what type of chicken
we want to serve the other thing that
was important for me was this crispy
sound when the skin is really crackling
and super crispy that's a happy sound to
me
so when you fried chicken at home you
want to fry it twice not once but twice
the second fry only fried for three
minutes it's gonna be super crispy and
super delicious
when i walk through the dining room and
i hear that sound and i hear like people
are really excited about biting into the
chicken you know they have the bib on
the thai if they're water thai is
probably on the side the hand's a little
bit messy they're biting into the
chicken that's a party that's eating
fried chicken at the red rooster
[Music]